[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILLIPO MADELLA: Hi, welcome to
Architecting with Google Cloud.
My name is Fillipo
Madella how many times
you're headed it
to your favorite
or need a dining spot that
you probably were in a rush
for an event which was about
to start or, like myself,
had hungry kids running around
and just wish the line wait
time wasn't that long.
I guess far too often, right.
So what if there was a way
to get in a priority queue
to avoid those long lines
and have a better experience?
Well, there is a way.
And today I invited
Gaurav Aggarwal--
he's the co-founder of Sleek--
to share a little bit more about
its AI and ML-based priority
lane solution that
retailers can implement
in just one line of
code and consumers
like us can enjoy
the shorter wait.
Welcome Gaurav to the show.
GAURAV AGGARWAL: Hey, Fillipo.
Great to be here.
Thanks for inviting me.
Yeah, really excited to be here.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Thank you.
Wow, it's our pleasure.
And it seems less time in line
sounds like an amazing idea.
So tell us a little bit more
about Sleek, how it works,
and how these actually
idea came about for you.
GAURAV AGGARWAL: Definitely.
Sleek is about giving
you your time back.
Imagine going to an event and
not having to wait in line.
You know, going to
the Indianas game
and not having to wait in
line to get in the event
and getting to
your seat, getting
a full drink, your
favorite merch,
or getting out of the event.
That is what we're trying to do.
We're trying to eliminate
line anywhere and everywhere.
It need not be stadium.
It can be your favorite
restaurant or your salon,
and any place where
there are products
and services to be sold.
And you can actually
get your time back.
You can just reserve your slot
for your product or service
and get back when
it's your time.
Or you can pay a
premium your fee
and take a Disney fast pass,
have a priority service
if you like.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Right.
Very interesting.
So I live in Texas.
And what if I owned this
very popular taco truck?
What do I need to do
to actually implement
Sleek solutions to
make my customers'
experience a little bit better?
AGGARWAL: So we
spend a lot of time
to make sure it is seamless
and easy for our vendors
to onboard on a
system because we
are trying to give them as
much ease of use as possible.
For you to go to
onboard our system,
you can sign up on
a website or you
can log-in with an official
partner like [INAUDIBLE]..
When you sign up,
you'll get an email.
And in the email,
you'll have a link.
The link very similar to--
once you click on the link,
you'll see a permission
page very similar to what
you see when you
sell an Android app
or when you click on a Facebook
app, and these sort of things.
You log in with your
POS credentials.
So POS mean Square,
Clover, Toast, these kind
of point of sale systems.
And just give us permission.
And that's it.
Voila, we're in the system.
We get all the historical data.
We can predict how
long it takes you
to make the burrito,
and all sorts of stuff.
We will generate a QR
code and a unique link
for your restaurant
or your place.
And you can place it on
a website, print it out.
And we'll definitely send you
marketing material for that,
to give you an exposure
that you can use, and even
put on Google Maps.
FILLIPO MADELLA:
OK, it seems very
straightforward and
easy to implement.
And you mentioned a
few use cases outside
of this restaurant industry.
Right?
So what other meaningful
use cases have you seen,
like, Slick Solutions
being applied for recently?
GAURAV AGGARWAL: A use case
that I'm very excited about
and I can personally
relate to is--
even you could, because
you work at Google,
you have these fancy cafeterias,
which have very nice food,
but it's always crowded.
And we are working with
our channel partners
to power some of these
commercial catering,
in some way.
So as an employee, you can
just reserve your meal.
You can say, hey, I want a
burrito and blah, blah, blah.
And then I can just
place the order.
And you'll get a text when
you can just go pick it up.
So you need not physically
wait in line and kind
of waste your time.
You can enjoy your time
with your colleagues
and do whatever you want.
So it just saves time
for you, gives you
like a fast pass, Disney
Pass kind of service,
and gives your time back.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Thank you.
To help us further with our
architecture conversation,
tell us a little about the
scale of your operations today
and how many customers usually
are using your solutions
on a daily basis?
GAURAV AGGARWAL: So we are
covering about 18,000 food
trucks via our partnership
with our channel partner
[INAUDIBLE].
And 18,000 is a very significant
portion of the food industry
in the United States.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Well, that
seems a lot to handle daily.
So let's then start
talking a little bit
about your infrastructure setup?
And how do you set up your
architecture stack today
to reach such scale
on an ongoing basis?
GAURAV AGGARWAL: So to
give you some context,
we are a very small team.
We have 10 employees across
engineering and other aspects.
And we are, like,
five engineers.
So we are a very small team.
And to handle at
such a large scale,
we cannot do everything--
DevOps, provisioning,
security, there
is just like so many
things going on.
And we [INAUDIBLE] to
focus on your business.
That's the kind of philosophy
that we have been following.
And that is one of the
reasons we chose Kubernetes.
It takes a lot of complexity
out of the system for us
so we can kind of
focus on our business
logic and our core
value proposition, which
is wait time and development.
So we use Kubernetes.
And Kubernetes takes care
of all the complexities like
networking, site creation
set-up, load balancing,
and all those--
the mission-critical
thing that you definitely
need in place and
you want to rely on.
And that's what
Kubernetes provides us.
All of our business logic sits
as, like, a stateless pod.
So [INAUDIBLE] Kubernetes
basically a docker image
that we kind of publish.
And it is used in the
Kubernetes as a pod.
We can easily
horizontally scale.
Like if we go from 18,000
to, like, 1 million,
we can begin throwing
in more parts,
and we can scale very easily.
That's the benefit
of Kubernetes.
And, actually, we
saved close to $100,000
from Kubernetes in
the last year or so,
which has been great for
us as a small salary.
Free money, it's always good.
And as a philosophy, we are
trying to cut down, as much as
possible, the DevOps.
As I said, we are
using managed services.
That's where GKE comes in and
plays a great role for us.
All the complexity
is taken care of.
It's a first grade
server within GCP.
We can integrate from our
other top provider, AWS.
So we were in AWS
before moving to GCP.
And some of our data
is still on AWS.
Like, there is a universe with
Cloud, Cloud for AWS, as a CBM.
And it works seamlessly
with our pods.
And MongoDB is the database.
So I would say very scalable
stack powered by multi-clouds.
And yeah, it works
for us right now.
FILLIPO MADELLA: You
mentioned a little bit
of your recent migration to GCP.
So what were the main technical
driving decisions that
let you to make that decision?
GAURAV AGGARWAL: So we were
using Kubernetes on AWS,
like we are using here.
And we started using AWS
because of different reasons.
We were using AWS when we were
not using Kubernetes, when
we were in [INAUDIBLE] stage.
Somehow, Kubernetes
was still, I would say,
getting into the AWS space.
A lot of things were missing.
We had to use third
party services
like Helm and Lens,
which is doable
when you are using massive
other aspects like the MongoDB.
But when you are
using AWS for just
Kubernetes and a
few other things,
it seemed a bit overkill.
And that's where we started
exploring other aspects
like GCP, Azure [INAUDIBLE].
And using GCP, it's very native.
Everything is kind
of part of GKE.
I rarely would have
to use Lens or Helm,
and these custom installing
systems and such.
Either I can do it from
the Google Cloud console
or like the [INAUDIBLE].
It works really well for us.
And that was one of the
main reasons we moved.
And obviously, Google
has its own benefit
of deep learning VMs.
And Google is known
for its own APIs.
We are using Google
Computer Vision APIs.
So that was also a
motivation for us.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Looking
at your infrastructure,
a lot of Sleek's
magic here comes
from the intelligent
infrastructure that you have
and the data you have
running on the edge.
So could you talk a little
bit about the edge component
of your infrastructure?
GAURAV AGGARWAL: Definitely.
So I just want to highlight,
why do we need each component?
Why can't we just, you know, get
data from point of the system,
and that should be enough?
So with point is the system,
you get historical data.
So we understand that launch
is going to be a busy time,
Friday evenings are a busy time.
But there are these
anomalous events,
like when you're
in a stadium, you
don't know when the game
is going to be scheduled.
It can be on the weekend,
but time can vary.
If you're a bar in front of
the stadium, you will have,
once the game is over,
a lot of people come in.
And so you need to
model this thing.
And we cannot ignore these
spikes because we are
in the business of giving
the right wait time most
of the time.
Although we can just say, 10
minutes wait time on average,
and you should be happy.
That's not how it works for us.
We need to be very accurate.
That's what we need to do to
figure out wait time on ground,
how many people are there?
And we have tried
computer vision.
We use state of the art
[INAUDIBLE] computer models.
And we wanted to be able
to do better than that.
But the privacy was a concern.
So we ended up using a very
proprietary technology,
where it's like a size
of, like, an iPhone,
where we have this thing
where you can plug in.
It detects how many people
are in the vicinity.
And it can make
a differentiation
in terms of how
many of these people
are employees, how many are
the customers potentially,
or how long the
people are there.
So we can get an idea
of the foot traffic.
And that kind of gives
us the real-time idea of,
OK, there's [INAUDIBLE]
people walked in,
and those sort of things.
And we feed all this data
in S3, for our AWS server
for long-term storage,
again, because we
were on AWS back then.
But are currently
being migrated to DCP4
for our modeling purposes.
FILLIPO MADELLA: So you are
leveraging machine learning
models to create a lot of these
priority cues and predictions.
So could you expand
a little bit more
on how you designed
this ML pipeline?
GAURAV AGGARWAL: Sure.
So we have these
small IT devices,
which gathers data and
sends this anonymous data
to our services.
So two types of data
sets are sent to us.
One type of data set is
the real-time, that kind of
feeds into our system.
And it is directly sent out to
our services running in GKE.
So it kind of gives an idea,
aggregated, of how many people
are there at time T, and
those sort of things.
More nuanced data, still
private, and fairly sensitive
data, that we do remove any kind
of identifiers and such things.
It's sent and it lies
in the S3 bucket for us.
And it is for archival storage.
Whenever we want to
update the model,
we move the data to Cloud
Storage, which is on GCP.
GCP provides a very
easy-to-move data, scripts,
and pipeline for us.
So we just use official
stuff for that.
We use GPC, GP-powered deep
learning VMs with PyTorch,
and train them all on these VMs.
And you know how the
model training works.
We train different
versions of the model
and post the model configuration
to GitHub, to docker, and then
kind of [INAUDIBLE] on
a flight experiment.
And GKE takes care of all
this stuff from there.
You know, like shipping
it is very easy for us.
If the matrix looks
fine, we can just
flip the time and
kind of make it look.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Great.
And you're using PyTorch
and deep learning
VMs, which are
computer-engineered virtual
machines that are pre-configured
with most popular machine
learning frameworks.
So I would love to
know a little bit more
how that experience
is like for you.
GAURAV AGGARWAL: So
it's not that I have
PyTorch as my favorite thing.
So our expert
engineer that Google
has been working with
us for some time,
he's an expert in Python.
And being a startup,
we needed the freedom
to choose how we
wanted to do things.
So that's how we are in PyTorch.
We have not seen any
kind of complaints.
And people are generally happy.
It's not that it's
a [INAUDIBLE]..
We never felt like that.
Everything is pre-installed.
There's no dependencies
to be handled.
And there's no issues like that.
Everything they do natively
integrates with our pipeline.
Even moving Cloud was very easy
for us when we moved from GCP.
So moving the pipeline has been
very easy for us, especially
the migration from
S3 to Cloud Storage.
I think that was the
main concern we had.
But even in that, it
was very easy for us.
FILLIPO MADELLA:
Thank you, Gaurav.
So to finalize a little
bit our conversation here,
there's a lot going
on, as we saw.
And so how do you monitor
everything that is happening?
And how is your
deployment routine?
How do you deploy
your applications?
GAURAV AGGARWAL: Our
deployment is very much
using Kubernetes pipelines.
We have all of our
coding in GitHub.
After every PR push,
there's a new label created
and our Docker image
is created, which
is pushed back to Kubernetes
on our flight experiment.
That runs for some time.
And then it is
uploaded to production,
depending on how the area is
laid and monitoring kind of
gives us any-- unless there's a
bad signal, it takes care of it
and it's being updated.
FILLIPO MADELLA:
Thank you, Gaurav.
We just saw how Sleek created
an AI-based priority lane
solution so we can all
get to our food service,
or any events quicker.
By building the infrastructure
on Google Cloud,
they save around
$100,000 just last year.
And by scaling their
serving platform on GKE
and training their ML models on
PyTorch using our deep learning
VMs, thousands of retailers
now can boost their profits
while improving their
on-site customer experience.
Thanks once more, Gaurav.
And thanks for being with us
today and for being a Google
Cloud customer.
GAURAV AGGARWAL:
Thanks, Fillipo.
Thanks for having me.
It was great chatting with you.
FILLIPO MADELLA: If you like
this session of Architecting
with Google Cloud, please make
sure to hit the Like button
and also to subscribe
so you can be
up-to-date to any
new upcoming sessions
on architecting solutions
on Google Cloud platform.
Thank you.